the reason i predicted nfts was because
of farm bill
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
may 5th before you watch this video may
5th i'm dropping it
huge project please please pay attention
to all my socials all my channels may
5th i've got a secret project i'm
dropping it with a complete focus
on making sure a that everybody's part
of this community my og
social media content youtube gets to
really win
wait do you see the way i structured
this this isn't just the art there's a
lot of
access and community and a lot of
[ __ ] thoughtfulness months and months
in the making may 5th be ready
have your metamask filled with as much
aetherium as you can afford
we're doing it
[Music]
hi gary how are you i saw i saw all the
waves and hugs and claps
hello they were all for you thank you so
much for joining us today and giving our
graduates some
helpful advice going into their careers
so with that i would love to give you
the stage
thank you uh first of all i refuse to
give this talk and q a session if this
many people are off screen
i need the humanity i need the faces
and there's way too many attractive
photos that i know are followed up by
real life there you go chris
thank you my god uh there we go fernando
good jessica thanks okay so i need that
for a couple seconds
dp just the whole fam's there i love it
everyone um great so i want to go into
as much q a as possible
in this short period of time but i'll
give a couple of words
um and then uh and then we'll go into
that so
uh first of all congratulations to
everybody i'm sure this is an important
big moment
you know i'm uh i'm extremely close to
my family so seeing some of these family
videos too has me pretty fired up um
it's obviously a big day
uh and i just want to congratulate all
of you for
you know achieving this goal that i'm
sure for many of you
was on your mind for a long time had its
challenges twists and turns
all those journeys do that you know as
somebody who's a historically terrible
student
i always have tremendous admiration to
anybody that can get to this point
so i i want to congratulate you on that
i think the the other thing that i
really want to talk about is the timing
of this and what you know
what it means in the scheme of the world
we now live in
you find yourself going into this next
chapter
in a time where the innovation
and the opportunity to be creative is
greater than ever
but the industry of advertising is at a
crossroads
where a lot of things of the past are
being held on a
pedestal at an emotional level and even
as those words started flowing out of my
mouth even though still there's way too
many people off screen
namakastan get in here biker doc
um uh the you know
when i just delivered that and this is
why i love having
you know your faces i can see by the
body language that many of you know we
are in massive transition
in communication and creativity you know
i'm sure many of you
and i see it every day in my halls and
everywhere in the industry like
there's a very interesting game of
not recognizing the internet
and i'm not kidding about that i am
fascinated but why
but but but and why and how and by
most of all of what is accepted or
believed to be true
for example
quantity the amount
that is put out is not debatable
if you make 13 commercials or nine
billboards or seven thousand
pinterest posts that is not a debate we
will all have to agree
that yes willie diaz put out six
tweets they were six there it is what is
incredibly
debatable is quality
and what has been the shocking thing for
me to get into this universe over the
last 13 years is
that a human being's subjective opinion
is wielded constantly
inside of agencies at the client level
and many other variables and it is
treated
in this wacky world of advertising as
truth which is the single most laughable
thing of all time you
i don't care if jessica simmons goes on
to win 77
cam lions when sh when she's in a
boardroom with me in 21 years
and she says this is right i'm going to
look at her face and say
you mean you think it's right and i
think this is a very important subject
matter and it's why i was so excited to
speak about this
i ask all of you because i want you to
be happy one of the things that has
really hurt me
looking at the creative industry both in
hollywood madison avenue everywhere
is there's actually a lot of unhappiness
in the industry because of the way that
people play the politics
around their opinions and i come here
and speak to you today
with the hope that this could be the
class
this could be the group that really
tries to take on
the baton even as you enter the game or
continue in the game to really have a
better conversation around opinions
these are subjective opinions
and to me that is the most important
elephant
in the room that once we get into
a healthy place as a community
of how we get to great work
until we get to that place we will
always have the shortcomings
of being one of the least creative
places on earth
i live in a lot of places not just
adland
i'm going to make this very clear to
everybody the least
creative place that i spend time is
adland
and we like to blame clients and that is
an escape
that is a falsity what is blame
is the insecurities and egos of senior
executives
in creative shops period end of story
and i am on a one-man mission
to talk about this in a healthy way does
this mean that creative directors and
ccos aren't talented
there's many great ones there's many
talented ones but let there be no
confusion
i actually have compassion and empathy
you work so hard for 12 years to finally
get your chance
to do what you want i literally believe
that every television commercial
every one of them is something i call
vanilla frankenstein
let me explain vanilla frankenstein i
come here today to warn you of
vanilla frankenstein vanilla
frankenstein is the following
from a client brief to a strategist
thinking to her handing it off to a
creative team to their ideas
hand it off to a production company that
hires a director
and then finally has to be post-edited
and improved by a client tested
in [ __ ] testing and then shown on
television that is frankenstein
that is not palma's idea anymore that is
a
a little piece because the way
television works it has to be vanilla
because they're trying to make that one
30 second video speak to everybody and
look at the beautiful
differences in faces genders ages
and definitely ideas interests and all
that in just this room let alone
the tremendous amount of the people on
the other side of a commercial
there's nothing scarier to me in the
world than vanilla frankenstein and it
is 99
of what this industry puts on a pedestal
and it's sad and it must change
and i hope that this class becomes some
of the voices that help
that to happen because that's the truth
because you know what else is the truth
as i see family members shake their
heads nobody's watching these goddamn
commercials
the hell are we talking about who
watches commercials
and so we are changing and this is good
this is not me
i'm not trying to this is this is good
it's not bad
i'm not by the way i'm not making fun of
the cr i love the creative industry
i just want us to be self-deprecating
self-aware
and honest to what's happening you know
meanwhile super bowl is the most
important stage in the world
everybody's watching that nothing is
more important to me
i think every day about next year's
super bowl for my clients now
but this is about attention and where
it's consumed and once you get to that
place
something else happens advertising was
easy for a long time
it was tv print radio
outdoor like you understood the rules
for a half a century
it's hard now being creative and getting
people to pay attention means you have
to understand the context of your
distribution that has always been
true from drawing in a cave to being on
tv
today understanding the context of what
works on tick tock versus
pinterest versus instagram versus a
pre-roll youtube
a television spot an ott spot a spotify
self-serve recorded ad
like it's all nfts are now in the
building i mean
do you understand what's going on
this is fun for you this should be fun
for you i have compassion for it to be
scary and not fun
to the incumbents and they will try to
make you
not think this is fun it's not their
fault they're wonderful human beings
that are worried about their families
and their well-being
and that's what's manifesting
it doesn't mean they're bad they're
insecure curious
concerned worried all the things all of
us humans should be that's what's
manifesting in the halls
of ad land it's a big change
it's big change it's not little change
there's a big change
and so what you're seeing is people
hunkering down on trying to
do one of two things i'm hunkering down
for the passion and conviction that i'm
coming across
in this talk on the other side
you have people who know they want to be
in business for another 12 years
who only know how to do it one way who
are hunkering down to keep the old way
stuck until they can retire and go to
miami
and so the reality is my friends is
come in eyes wide open come into this
industry
eyes wide open continue your journey in
this industry eyes wide open
there's so much opportunity it actually
is about to get creative
but you need to be a voice and let me
explain what i mean by that
there's never been an era like this
so there's some of us in here with gray
hairs and
we all know that 23 year olds and 25
year olds and 27 year olds
didn't have a voice at the table when we
were your age today you do
you take that for granted i love your
audacity
and ambitions and conviction
it comes with some delusion but we
should all we all still have delusion
um don't be hurt palma but you know i'm
telling you right now listen
take advantage that you have a voice
there's a way to listen
i own my own business there is no board
i fully control it
i can be a tough guy on linkedin and all
these platforms
you are gonna have a job somebody's your
boss and their boss and a boss and a
boss and a boss
so you're gonna have to deliver this
conviction in a far more politically
correct way
but it doesn't mean that you should be
quiet the number one thing i can tell
you and then i will go into q a
if george if you believe you're in the
room and they're saying something
about something you understand whether
that's tick-tock
right whether that's linkedin whether
that whatever that is
do not die on someone else's sword
every day i walk and i'm in meetings and
i see people
biting their tongue because they don't
agree a lot of times they don't agree
with me because they came from other
agencies
and i make it safe for them to have
dialogue
i'm a weird kind of character in the
game you're going to be in a lot of
rooms where it's going to feel a lot
less safe to do that
that is where you're going to have to
have courage and that's what i'm coming
with here
to say what you believe in a respectful
manner let me tell you why
in this change a lot of things are going
to happen
many of you are going to find yourself
in a place where you're not going to
want to say something because you don't
want to
come off as disruptive or things that
nature
but it is in those words where if you
end up being historically correct
you will have your opportunities in the
future
it's very important now another very
important part of that when you share
your thoughts
remember that this is business and
here's what i mean by that
i've watched incredible amounts of
people come into my company
and have incredible passion because we
make it safe and they spit all their
favorite words
and they forget that they're coming from
a place of just worrying about the
creativity of it
not about the practicality of it people
come with all sorts of ideas
ideas are cute but when you're doing it
for business stakes you need the context
of that reality
you might like it but the person that's
receiving that
may not like it and then they're not
gonna buy that donut you understand
so self-awareness but conviction
about things you know to be true in a
time where it's never been
more thoughtful and opportunistic to
share that
i'm very humbled to be with you today
i'll open it up for q a now thank you
for having me
that's amazing thank you gary that's
awesome i love
i love that speech um so with that i'm
gonna um
open the q a why don't we start with
priscilla
i'm sure you have a question go ahead
yes i
have hi thank you thank you thank you so
much
you're welcome thank you so much really
grateful to have you here okay so my
first question
is are you hiring yes big time
listen i'm a nice guy but i'm here for
my own agenda too
we're hiring so get your apps in we are
busy
love that love that okay but actual
actual question
is i've seen how you back in 2010 you
had an interview and you predicted
the technology the apps you talked about
snapchat you talked about
a little bit about twitter and you even
predicted the nfts and
you even mentioned it we are we right
now we're thinking about nfds and how
can we get that in the way so
i don't want to know how no never mind i
want to know how you did it
not the predictions of the future but
how could you pinpoint
the tendencies the culture and
everything and you predicted this
you know it's funny when you have my
personality traits
people oftentimes think you're always
talking
you're a big mouth you're all this and
that i spend 98
of my time listening that's how
every second you don't see me doing this
i'm listening
i'm watching i have incredible i was you
know you also have to be self aware of
what you were gifted with i
believe in doubling down on your natural
strengths i was gifted with intuition
and curiosity and humility and sometimes
those aren't obvious with gary vee
on a piece of content but they are
absolutely my superpowers
and i rarely think i'm right i just
think i'm observing
and i really think about that stuff and
i watch and i listen
and i understand how humans are wired
and i keep refining that
and listening and refining i have
humility when i'm wrong
i like when i'm wrong to be honest with
you it keeps you intact and i go and i
go and i
move and i move and i move and i and you
know i'm experienced you know don't
forget i'm a little bit unique
i have really been an entrepreneur and a
listener and a seller and a
marketer since i was six the reason i
made that joke about school
i was a businessman in junior high let
alone high school like i spent my
weekends at baseball card shows and i
would watch people
how they would come to my table why
would they buy that i would talk to
people
you know at seven eight nine i'm ringing
doorbells trying to
sell them my services to shovel their
driveway after a snowstorm or wash their
car
you know when i was seven years old i
was sitting
on the corner of new jersey streets
watching cars drive by
and looking at the driver's face to
figure out where to put my lemonade
stand stein
this has been my game my whole life i've
been chasing attention and understanding
what people do my whole life
so at 45 i'm refined i'm i'm a vet
this is you know this is not something i
went to school with this is who i
am and so i stand out
because i don't talk about things i
don't know
which absolutely destroys people so what
that does is it lets
you know i love showing all these old
videos as you see
right and the reason that people that
razz me or compete with me
don't have a lot of video to say [ __ ]
gary v look at all these wrong things is
i don't say a lot of things wrong and
here's why priscilla most of what i talk
about
isn't predicting let me give you an
insight to why i was so right about nfts
you ready i'm gonna get i've never
shared this but i'm giving it to you
because i like your hair and i'm in the
mood
ready
the reason i predicted nfts ish right
because obviously i didn't know
blockchain was coming
was because of farm bill
right i understood that our lives were
becoming more
and more digital and i
started watching people do things for
sheep and spending money and i
understood that the same reason that
somebody wants to wear a gucci
bag to flex or ride a bmw humans need to
communicate
through their purchases that's why the
fashion industry exists otherwise we'd
all wear
the same thing you know jessica's
wearing those glasses
because she's trying to communicate
right you you know like this is what we
do we communicate
right eric p's got his look right like
we communicate
and so as we become more digital
the things we own in digital form take
over
for a pair of jordas jeans in 1983
take over for fresh nike collab
off-whites today
they take over and it's coming and it's
gonna be real and i'm gonna be right
while everybody thinks i'm wrong
because they're looking at things
literally and i'm thinking about things
from a macro human
standpoint
wow that's a good question good answer
eric you're next okay
uh well mine uh my question will be
actually uh you said that you love being
wrong
yes and my question goes around that
part and about how you deal with uh your
mistake how you learn from every time
that you
thought oh this is the next thing and
you have to stay quiet because it wasn't
you know but how do you handle that
easily by and i'm going to give you a
very interesting answer to this question
eric
the reason i deal so well with being
wrong which happens all the time
is because i don't get high when i'm
right
do you want to know the easiest way to
deal with booing or with negative
comments
don't listen to the cheering and
positive comments
i think the reason it's good for me eric
is because i stay in my
very small cocoon within my own head
right in the middle
i listen i'm living a life right now
where i have a lot of accolades
and when i tell you you can't imagine
how much
i don't if i disappear off the face of
the earth tomorrow i'll get 12
hours of some love on social media and
everybody here will move on with their
lives
when you have the humility to know you
mean nothing but the ambition to mean
everything
[ __ ] gets real interesting
thank you thank you interesting
surely you are up next uh
uh thank you for everything like it was
very inspiring and i really resonated
with everything
thank you you're good
my question goes on the line of have you
ever
been afraid of the path that you were
walking
and like maybe you felt like
maybe like this is not my path and maybe
i should do something else and like how
you fought that and how
like you encouraged yourself to like go
on and do
like how do you know when i don't know
if i'm complicating this question too
much but you're not close
yeah not only are you not complicating
it you're
you're you're exposing feelings
and i can tell you right now you have to
do the thing that you actually feel
whatever the practical part of you like
so i believe
and i hope i get to see it but i think
it's going to take some time
i believe that intuition is
uncomfortably misunderstood
in society and i hope like alcoholism
and mental health that i'll be on earth
when we get to
talking about intuition in a far more
thoughtful way than we talk about it now
so i live sure in a way
where my intuition
trumps every thought i have every
logical thing
that you can tell me if my chemicals are
telling me something else
there's not even a debate if my
chemicals tell me i have to live
under water like a fish right now in a
submarine
i would literally walk out of this room
right now and do that
i think you have to start trusting your
intuition and if you're asking that
question
you already know the answer you're just
dealing with the fear of the
ramifications
and the way i talk about fear of
ramifications is the following
you have to be humble and empathetic let
me explain
a lot of times people don't want to do
something else because it financially
hurts them
and they don't have the humility to live
by taking one step backwards
a lesser home a lesser car a lesser
vacation
right so that's the humility that's
needed to make the jump
and then empathy the reason most people
don't make jumps
is they value other people's opinions
more than their own happiness
instead of being mad at yourself or even
them
i try to get people to understand be
empathetic to your mom and dad they love
you that means they're scared
by nature love means fear
so if you're going to be a stand-up
comedian after you decided to spend all
this money on education
they're gonna be scared but don't be mad
at them
and definitely don't be scared for
yourself you just know you need to go do
it
you have to be empathetic that of course
they're gonna be scared or pissed if
they paid for your education
it's but it's your life and i can
promise you one thing
when i was a child i spent a lot of time
with 70 and 80 year old people i'm not
kidding it was the weirdest thing and
finally in my mid-40s i'm starting to
understand it
whether i was born an old soul whether
wisdom came naturally to me
or who that or because i did this and
felt comfortable with grandparents
did i become a little bit more wise and
have what didn't rub off on me
i can promise you something surely
there's nothing scarier in the world
outside of the health and well-being of
yourself and your loved ones which is
number one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
number eleven is regret
there's nothing scarier than regret you
want to see real pain
outside of death and illness go talk to
somebody who's 67
74 82 91 talk about
life they will always talk
with pain in their eyes about the things
they didn't do
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you